haha the Joe Rogan experience Steven
Naismith said thank you you guys didn't
grapple cuz you were afraid of karate he
said he meant I thought you were told he
meant it he did say it he meant it
[ __ ] meant it we're literally
swapping blood here yeah HIV world
hepatitis war yes yes every day you name
it you get it yeah everything anything
through blood but that kind of that kind
of talk
Steven Naismith though he's a
personality like that take some things
he could have not meant to he could be
as smart as smarter than we think and
said it because of yeah it's a lot
listen he makes his living that way
we're all talking about him that's how
he's very engaging to use that in the
next interview Joe was coming for last
seven years I hit him so hard so scared
he was gonna touch me get that Corona on
me break up on the fight I think people
are like why didn't he grapple and a
huge factor and the kabhi fight is gonna
be my feet work yeah there was never a
spot when he felt comfortable to close
the distance I was constantly too far
away and staying off the fence so that's
gonna be huge against Habib well you
have a the the star I mean if you wanted
to say okay what kind of style do you
think would work against a guy like
could be first of all guy was a
fantastic defensive wrestler like you
said and then a guy was a superior
striker and though those two things you
have you got a staff defense yeah you
gotta have feet work without the viewer
you can't see out the fence but khabib
'he's whole game is you know he's a
great grappler as well with his whole
game is using that grappling in the
fight against the fence yeah you will
not if he's taking a shot in the
openness to drive you to the fence to
finish the takedown
he's not getting takedowns in the open
interesting you go watch all this fights
right you're gonna see maybe five a
handful if that
take downs in the actual center of the
kids he'll start in the middle but he's
gonna push its to push you to the cage
and use the cage it's gonna be my feet
work it's gonna be me keeping that
distance where he feels slightly
uncomfortable like when he did go for
them now I was just too far he thought
it was close enough but I was just too
far right but he was already beaten down
yeah it was super sneaky like you wanna
hit up Barbeau suppose it would have
been the same in the first round because
the distance I was keeper you know you
have to in order to shoot a double leg
you have to be at a distance in would
you feel comfortable in wrestling it's
always you know I shouldn't unless my
head touching your head I should never
take a shot because I'm too far away
right so controlling distance staying
off the vent is gonna be the most
important thing in the world when it
comes to that fight now when are they
talking about for that fight I mean we
got the same manager so that's kind of
crazy whenever we want
g-man so the fight with you and could be
we both have the same manager what
you're talking about September they say
that with you that means so we again we
both pretty much we decide I mean I hope
they have a [ __ ] on we don't have we
don't decide the UFC is the boss they
know but you can't make anybody fight
and I'm ready in September he's ready in
September so it's perfect now I know
Vegas is going to at least allow some
audiences in July supposedly because I'm
at that Park Theatre the one that's
right across the street from Tito I'm
there in July from doing a comedy show
it's supposedly gonna actually happen
they haven't canceled it they haven't
cancelled it my guards really hope right
new jersey opened up pro sports with an
audience I don't believe so yeah that's
huge you and khabib I mean as much as it
was cool to see you and Tony fight with
no audience as much as I loved fighting
with no audience I want them there the
spectacle of the fight that's such a
challenge of his career it's the biggest
challenge of khabib career it's the
biggest challenge of your career 100%
yeah I mean he's the greatest that's
what he does like that's again we can't
take anything away from that it's you
when you look at well-rounded fighters
he's well-rounded but he's great and one
what he does and that is like what mate
Chuck Liddell great like he had done
in his hands and he sprawl and brawl
like you you get hit by him he's great
at what he does and that's what's so
exciting is having opportunities to be
able to step up that's what I'm really
excited for I know he's excited for and
again no one's got to see his wrestling
and I've met this guy watching him
wrestle of what he does was so unique
it's a total different style of
wrestling then that's hard to train for
and it's kind of like a hidden weapon so
I feel like we're bringing something
unique into this I think it's it's a
very unique fight and it's also tony was
thought to be the biggest threat to that
title because tony is such a good
grappler and he's so good on his feet
and he [ __ ] people up on his feet so
him fighting you and you stopping him
like you take that spot now and also
your style in my opinion is better
oh I mean the thing about Tony Styles as
Tony can fight off of his back he's not
worried about takedowns he was gonna
fight that fight with the mindset of
being okay on his back yes that was the
thought process whereas your thought
process is completely different being
such a great defensive wrestler but also
being the superior striker total it's a
very dangerous Pfeifer could be very
dangerous especially the confidence you
must have coming out for that five
rounds with Tony it was good I mean I
know how bad those kicks hurt I you know
if you if I can touch your calf I'm not
I'm never kicking above the knee anymore
really only below you ever know I'm
pretty well not on purpose I never
really it's so devastating the clinch
you're gonna kick above me I'll try to
break your knee by but from the outside
you could fire that different distance
you're so much more safe mm-hmm
and there's so many nerves and ligaments
that run through that part they have no
protection your thigh as you know your
your quad is a big muscle it's hard to
get through your quad to you you have to
those nerves you could touch the nerves
that's why you know when he said Henry's
calf and foot don't hurt it's cuz I got
kicked in the calf you know the nerve
stop firing yeah I can touch I got a
touch beep there four times and then
he's compromised
yeah once he's compromised he can't
shoot he can shoot but he has to have
the fence right if he doesn't have the
fence Heath [ __ ] there's no [ __ ] way
yeah promise you that has
in the middle so he can give me there
might be a scramble here my out scramble
me in the middle once or twice but if he
wants to take me he's gonna have to put
me against the fence
now once they set this fight you you
need eight weeks is that what you want
to get prepared yeah so we're getting
close to that right
we're in June and in just a week or so
yep June July August yeah so I'm taking
I take 30 days off but they didn't give
you a specific thing yeah just my major
probably knows more details than I do
fine island seems like there's not lots
yeah it does it's like [ __ ] that
movie contact or the zoom in zooming
tells me everything you won't tell me
I'm not sure if it's real yeah might be
just saying it just so he could get a
set for his fights it seems like the
only option yes you ain't getting visas
right now no you're not getting visas
and I don't even know how they got there
have to fly everybody private to this
[ __ ] Island yeah what I want to know
if I can get back right yeah that's the
thing right where you gonna land
your witness includes the flight if you
lose you got that boat no work you
landed to you wanna and then you have a
boat you gotta get to San Diego and then
we drive you home
[Laughter]
[Applause]